[Musik]
ein nicht so wunderschöner Morgen denn
es ist gerade Nacht erwartet uns hier in
unserer kleinen süßen Minecraft also
meine lieben Freunde zum Ende der
letzten Folge habe ich euch ja gesagt
ich gehe auf eine Challenge ein und
versuche diese Challenge umzusetzen dass
ich dass ich drei Tage lang nicht
schlafe in meiner Minecraft Welt weil
mir gesagt wurde dass ich das nicht
schaffe und ich dachte es geht dabei nur
um Monster die dann eventuell ankommen
aber nein mir wurde in die Kommentare
geschrieben dass dann auch Phantom ist
worden
nicht mit mir
wir starten ganz normal wie sonst auch
immer in die Minecraft Folge nämlich mit
einem wunderschönen guten Morgen äh da
habt ihr mich wirklich bisschen an der
Nase herum
ich bin ein alman so wir haben für heute
allerdings ein etwas vor und zwar
was soll ich mit euch machen
komm dann gehen wir eine kleine Runde
Gassi Balu sehen sie können den später
[Musik]
ganz kurz wieder zurück ins Wasser und
bei Ludo kleiner blöder Idiot ich packe
ich auch direkt mal wieder zurück hier
ins ist ja noch einer
den hast du nur die Schildkröten hier
also balu ist drin und Balenciaga ist
drin und jetzt meine lieben Freunde
zeige ich euch erstmal ganz kurz was ich
in der heutigen Episode vorhabe denn das
habe ich ja schon in der letzten Episode
angekündigt ich möchte hier vorne hallo
Pepper ich möchte hier vorne einen
Luftballon hinbauen bzw vielleicht auch
noch ein paar mehr die Sache ist
allerdings dass ich in meiner testwelt
schon geschaut habe wie viele Ressourcen
ich eigentlich habe und ich habe nicht
mal die Ressourcen für einen Luftballon
von daher um solche erstmal ganz kurz zu
erklären ich brauche eine Menge Beton
und ich brauche auf jeden Fall noch ein
halbes Deck Sand und noch mehr als ein
Stack Kies deswegen würde ich direkt mal
runtergehen in die Hölle Höhle nicht in
die Hölle das sind zwei verschiedene
Welten und gönnen mir hier erstmal ein
bisschen Sand den brauchen wir eh nicht
den habe ich ja damals nur hier
hingebaut weil ich halt dachte dass ich
hier eventuell eine Bambus Farm mache
bzw zuckerrohrfarben und das ist ja doch
nichts geworden soll immer noch der
Bunker rein keine Ahnung ob ich den noch
bauen werde ich will eigentlich die
ganzen Projekte die ich noch habe
umsetzen während dieser letzten 19
Folgen mittlerweile ja nur noch
allerdings euch jetzt meine ganz große
timeless wie ich hier den Sand abbaue
wie ich mir noch Kies hole und generell
wie die Sachen zusammen crafte die ich
für den Luftballon benötige
[Musik]
so ich bin fertig vorbereitet und ihr
seht auch schon ich habe hier eine Menge
roten trockenbeton ich habe eine Menge
Fichtenholz Dinge wie beispielsweise
Bretter Zäune Zaun Tore und Stufen und
ich habe auch schon Seerosenblätter in
der Hand denn das Seerosenblatt wird uns
nachher helfen dass wir uns passend hoch
bauen können denn der Ballon soll direkt
hier vorne stattfinden ich habe mir erst
gedacht dass ich in woanders hinsetzt
das kann ich euch sofort zeigen ich
musste allerdings erstmal hier ganz kurz
markieren hier vorne soll er nämlich
sein sogar sehr sehr nah hier vorne dran
ihr seht nachher auch warum der wird
nämlich nicht allzu riesig denn der hat
auch gar keine Funktion und soll einfach
ein Deko Element sein ich wollte den
erst hier vorne hin bauen dort denn in
die Richtung haben wir noch gar nichts
die Sache ist allerdings dass hier die
Südseite ist und die Sonne scheint den
Ballon dann von der falschen Seite an
und dann wirkt der auch wenn der rot ist
ziemlich dunkel und ähm sieht nicht so
schön aus dann wirft ja auch ein
Schatten auf unsere Insel die Sache ist
allerdings dass ich ja leider roten
trocken Beton habe ich benötige
allerdings normalen Beton und deswegen
muss ich den jetzt erstmal hier
ordentlich dransetzen
[Musik]
so Freunde seid jetzt doch noch mal 12
Minuten gedauert den ganzen trockenbeton
hier hinzusetzen und wieder abzubauen so
dass es normaler Beton wird allerdings
habe ich jetzt 220 oder sogar noch ein
bisschen mehr von dem trockenbeton damit
müssen wir allerdings gar nicht erst mal
anfangen sondern erstmal mit dem
fichtenholzbrettern ihr wisst ja ich
liebe Fichtenholz deswegen mache ich
auch hier den Ballon aus Fichtenholz und
ich habe mir auch gerade überlegt dass
ich den vielleicht doch noch ein
bisschen weiter vorne ins Meer einsetze
weil so ein Ballon der fliegt ja auch
immer nie so nah an Häusern her von
daher hier erstmal das Seerosenblatt hin
und die frage ich jetzt wahrscheinlich
warum hier ein Seerosenblatt ganz
einfach aus dem Grund weil ich mich
sonst vom Boden aus bis nach oben hoch
bauen müsste um hier überhaupt den
ersten richtigen Block hinsetzen zu
können und jetzt kann ich einfach so
machen Zack und hier ein Block hinsetzen
und ich habe auch noch extra ein
bisschen mehr Fichtenholz mitgebracht so
dass ich das so ein bisschen als
Plattform benutzen kann ich baue den
Ballon jetzt auf jeden Fall in ein zwei
drei vier fünf Komplex 7 8 9 10 11
12-fache Höhe so dass so oder vielleicht
sogar noch ein bisschen niedriger glaube
ich weil das hier unten ist ja die
Situation
warum sage ich so oft Situation
mach gar keinen Sinn auf jeden Fall
geht's hier los denn das hier ist äh der
Bereich wo man dann quasi drin steht da
werden wir zwar nie drin stehen ich habe
es halt zu Beginn schon gesagt es ist
eher ein Deko Element der balloon hier
vorne allerdings äh muss auch das
natürlich durchdacht sein von daher hier
dies äh Eingangstor oder kann ich quasi
reingehen äh hier vorne auch noch mal
Fichtenholz Bretter hin und hier an die
Seiten Fichtenholz Zäune so das ist ganz
natürlich gut gesichert ist aber es soll
aufgefallen dass so ein Ballon dass er
null gesichert ne
überleg mal im Flieger du schnalst dich
an du hast das an sicherheitssachen und
dies und blau sind Ballon
du musst einmal so ein Vogel rein und
BAM
vom Himmel das passiert uns in Minecraft
natürlich nicht denn hier gibt es
perfekt hier gibt es tatsächlich keine
Vögel eventuell gibt es die allerdings
in äh die Staffel 2 von Minecraft mit
Luca müssen wir mal abwarten ob ich da
so eine Mod installiere dass er so ein
paar Tiere mit drin sind allerdings
konzentrieren wir uns erstmal noch auf
diese Staffel hier denn wir müssen uns
jetzt erstmal ganz kurz hoch bauen bzw
die Blöcke unter uns auch direkt wieder
abbauen denn die sollen wir natürlich
nicht bleiben das ist schon ein bisschen
schwierig dass wir uns jetzt gerade in
dieser schwindeligen Höhe hier fortbauen
das war's auf jeden Fall was will die
ganzen Fichtenholz machen mussten wir
mussten erstmal ganz kurz hier vorne
hochkommen und hier kommen
kommen sie wirklich dumm hier kommen wir
jetzt nämlich auch schon zu unserem
richtigen Ballon also zu diesem Ding
diesen ist das Stoff ich habe keine
Ahnung ist mir auch egal ich finde das
alles ein bisschen suspekt perfekt
direkt den ersten Block hier falsch
gesetzt äh ihr seht schon ich habe hier
da wo die Zäune hochgehen einen roten
Kreis drum gesetzt und jetzt kommt an
jede Seite hier Zack und hier auch noch
mal Zack und hier auch Sack roter Beton
dran hier gehen wir jetzt mal einen
höher die Sache ist äh ihr könnt das
ganze natürlich auch aus Wolle bauen
sieht dann wahrscheinlich sogar noch ein
bisschen geiler aus allerdings ist wolle
schwierig in Minecraft wenn man entweder
eine Menge Fäden für oder eine Menge
Schafe ich habe weder noch
und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich
mache es mit Beton weil das mit Kies und
Sand ein bisschen besser aussieht und
ich finde auch die Farben ehrlich gesagt
so ein bisschen Cleaner als wolle sobald
wir diesen eckigen Kreis jetzt haben
bauen wir auf jede Spitze sondern
kleines t also ein so ein Block steht
dir ab und dann brauchen wir da oben
quasi drei Betonblöcke noch mal drauf
und dann hier drinnen baut man das ganze
so also 12 zack nee das ist falsch
[Musik]
so bauen wir das Ganze also hier Bam Bam
und dann immer einen nach außen also so
und hier vorne auch Bam Bam Bam und hier
vorne auch Bam Bam Bam das Video wenn
ihr das ganze nachbauen wollt pack ich
euch wahrscheinlich natürlich wieder
unten in die Beschreibung also checkt
das gerne aus und wenn ihr schon in der
Beschreibung seid könnt ihr noch auf
Instagram folgen dann neues Foto
hochgeladen
drei Wochen neues Foto hochgeladen jetzt
gehen wir an den Seiten auf jeden Fall
fünf Blöcke in jede Richtung bzw hier
haben wir drei Blöcke und dann gehen wir
noch mal einen Block weiter genau das
gleiche nun auch auf dieser Seite und
dann auch jetzt hier vorne auf der
letzten Seite Zack und zack und jetzt
gehen wir hier auf jeder Seite zwei
Blöcke in die Höhe allerdings auch hier
vorne über die Seiten rum so dass das
hier quasi so jetzt mittlerweile sogar
schon der Mittelpunkt vom Leuchtturm ist
der war wieder falsch perfekt so zack
zack die Sache ist dass ein Ballon
alleine mal so ein bisschen einsam
aussieht finde ich gerade wenn man so am
Himmel so ein Ballon sieht finde ich das
immer so ein bisschen weird deswegen
habe ich mir überlegt dass wir eventuell
demnächst noch mal ein paar mehr Ballons
bauen und dann nicht nur einen roten
Ballon haben sondern dann noch irgendwie
einen blauen hier neben so ein bisschen
tiefer und noch einen gelben oder so
hier so ein bisschen höher könnt ihr mir
gerne in die Kommentare schreiben was
ihr davon haltet nun gehen wir oben
allerdings wieder so ein bisschen
spitzer zu und machen das nicht über die
komplette Länge sondern wieder nur fünf
Betonblöcke und auf die fünf Betonblöcke
setzen dann auch nur noch mal drei
Betonblöcke also quasi genauso wie wir
das unten gemacht haben und jetzt auch
wieder auf der Innenseite unser l wo ich
mich zu Beginn ein bisschen verbaut habe
leider nun sind wir hier oben angekommen
und bauen nur noch diese Ecken hier eben
fix zu dann hier vorne eins zwei drei
eins Moment 1 2 3 1 2 3 und hier nochmal
eins zwei drei und dann nur noch das
hier in der Mitte schnell zu bauen dann
sind wir quasi schon fertig mit dem
Ballon die Sache ist allerdings dass wir
hier an die Seiten jetzt auch noch etwas
dran bauen müssen und da ist jetzt die
Frage wie ich das mache ich muss mich
dazu ein bisschen herangehen denn hier
in die Mitte muss ein Block dann müssen
hier welche runter wir müssen dann
allerdings auch wieder ein bisschen
weiter runter ich hoffe dass ich das
jetzt irgendwie hinkriege das ist halt
ein bisschen blöd wenn man hier in so
einer schwindligen Höhe baut ich hoffe
mal ich pack das jetzt da irgendwie
runter zu gehen also einmal so zack zack
hier das Fichtenholz abgebaut und dann
hier noch mal Bam Bam Bam und hier vorne
auch noch einen ich hoffe mal dass ich
ich kann jetzt nicht hin so ich hoffe
mal dass das jetzt richtig gebaut habe
das gleiche müssen wir jetzt auch noch
mal hier auf die andere Seite bauen also
ich hier einen Block hin hier dann zack
Linie Richtung und hier noch mal das
sollte allerdings richtig sein von daher
baue ich mich jetzt hier auch noch mal
zur anderen Seite eben rum das ist auf
jeden Fall sehr gut so wie ich das
gerade machen mit dem Gerüst was ich mir
so ein bisschen drumherum setze wenn man
das im Creative Modus natürlich danach
baut also ihr dann beispielsweise in
eurer Welt dann kann man da natürlich
ein bisschen einfacher einfach drumherum
fliegen und so das ist für mich jetzt
allerdings gerade natürlich nicht
möglich einen letzten eichenholzblock
habe ich noch und das passt jetzt auch
perfekt ins Bam Bam Bam und Bam Bam Bam
und BAM dann sollte der Ballon auch
eigentlich schon fertig sein ich brauche
sie mal ganz fix das Gerüst hier eben
drumherum ab das brauche ich jetzt auf
jeden Fall nicht mal das sieht nachher
nur blöd aus die Sache ist dass die
Sonne da hinten tatsächlich jetzt schon
wieder untergeht und an der Stelle würde
ich dann auch gleich die heutige Episode
Minecraft mit Luca beenden ich weiß
nicht ob die Folge jetzt ein bisschen
länger war oder ein bisschen kürzer ich
bin halt in der Aufnahme schon wieder
bei fast einer Stunde es waren
allerdings natürlich wieder zwei sehr
lange time labsis mit drin die Sache ist
allerdings dass ich gerade leider wieder
ein bisschen Stress ich muss gleich mein
Zug erwischen weil ich nach Berlin fahre
übers Wochenende die nächste Folge wird
aber definitiv wieder ein bisschen
länger das haben sich ja viele gewünscht
dass man die langen Episoden
zurückkommen sollen ähm ich bau erstmal
ganz kurz fällt mir mal eben auf hier
vorne meinen Gerüst auch ab das geht ja
noch bis zum Ballon oben hin ich hoffe
dass ich jetzt überhaupt dran kommen
sonst muss ich mich da gleich auch noch
ein bisschen hoch bauen und perfekt es
hat geklappt okay super hier vorne noch
mal kurz das Fichtenholz abbauen und den
untersten Block auch hier vorne das
Seerosenblatt und dann sammle ich jetzt
noch mal eben fix hier meine ganzen
Bretter ein die hier vorne noch überall
rum schwimmen guck mal hier im Wasser
die Fische ey das ist echt wundervoll
ich weiß noch genau die erste Episode
Minecraft mit Luca wo ich auf dieser
kleinen Insel da hinten gespannt bin wo
mittlerweile ja der Leuchtturm steht und
drüber geschwommen bin und überhaupt
erstmal das ganze Seetang hier gesehen
habe die ganzen Fische gesehen habe und
mir einfach nur AUA ich dachte schon ich
werde angegriffen
ich habe einfach wieder keine Luft
bekommen die Sonne geht unter
das war doch dieser Fisch
wir haben heute nur positive vibes in
der Folge denn wir haben einen Ballon oh
mein Gott der sieht voll nice aus
Alter das hätte ich niemals gedacht dass
der doch so wild aussieht
vor allem mit dem Himmel im Hintergrund
[Musik]
mal ganz kurz hier dem Michael Fans
rausholen ich gehe auch mal ganz fix
eben schnell schlafen so dass wir uns
den Sonnenaufgang noch mal mit dem
Ballon zusammen angucken können also
eben ganz schnell hier nach oben den
Villager im upstala in Villager eben
kurz aus dem Bett verjagen BAM rein hier
und dann können wir uns den Ballon jetzt
noch mal beim Sonnenaufgang angucken und
dann zeige ich euch auch warum es mehr
Sinn machte den Ballon dorthin zu setzen
anstatt was ich ja irgendwann mal
angekündigt habe da vorne noch was hin
zu bauen denn das jetzt wirklich sehr
wild
so zwischen den Bäumen da vorne so ein
Ballon den stellt euch vorhin neben noch
so ein kleiner blauer und hier irgendwie
so ein gelber noch irgendwie in der
das auch besser so denn ich gehe jetzt
auch meine lieben Freunde wenn es euch
heute gefallen hat gib mir Episode
Minecraft mit Luca dann lasst gern einen
Daumen hoch und ein Video hier da
abonniert meinen Kanal und klickt auf
die Glocke falls noch kein unter der
Lucy seid und neue Videos nicht
verpassen wollt schreibt mir zu geben
bitte bitte bitte bitte bitte bitte gern
unten in die Kommentare was hier in der
nächste Episode machen soll soll ich äh
die beiden Ballons in der nächsten
Episode vielleicht direkt schon bauen
der sieht schon echt sehr sehr sehr wild
aus da vorne am Horizont oder soll ich
in die Höhle gehen die wir hinten in der
Wüste entdeckt haben oder soll ich etwas
ganz anderes machen soll ich mal wieder
in die Hölle gehen schreibt so in die
Kommentare wir sehen uns übermorgen
wieder
auch
[Musik]